vous téléphonez vous en doutez pour vous
annoncer que le résultat est revenu
positif pour le coc ville dans les
bureaux de la santé publique en
montérégie
l'emploi du temps est bousculé par le
coronavirus ici c'est un peu le centre
des opérations des médecins et des
infirmières tente de retracer les
personnes infectées grassois des
signalements qui nous proviennent soit
du gouvernement soit de info-santé 8-1-1
et puis une fois qu'on ait reçu des
signalements là on analyse qui est ce
qu'on va appeler pour elle passe un coup
de fil à une personne qui a passé un
test pour lui annoncer qu'elle a
contracté la coved 19 à partir d'un
questionnaire de santé canada elle fait
le profil de cette personne et surtout
l'historique de ses déplacements depuis
l'infection c'est ce qu'on appelle une
enquête épidémiologique donc depuis 15
avec des symptômes
c'est depuis le mardi quelles ont été
vos activités le mardi où vous êtes vous
déplacer avez vous de la visite à
domicile dans vos déplacements vous avez
visité des commerces quel commerce quel
type de contact c'est ce qu'a fait la
santé publique avec une dame de
longueuil revenu de voyage la semaine
dernière avec la coved 19 et l'a pris
l'autobus et le métro sur des lignes
particulièrement achalandé c'est pas un
contact extrêmement prolonger mais c'est
dans un même eu lieu pendant un certain
temps donc on juge qu'un risque faible
donc on va dire surveiller dans les 14
jours qui ont suivi cette exposition le
vous développez de la toux ou de la
fièvre des douleurs thoraciques appeler
info santé 1ère 0246 chaque personne un
fake quatre personnes qui chacune de ces
personnes là en effet que quatre os
puisque on essaye de faire c'est que
chaque personne ne put sont infectés
pops qu'une l'enjeu est là selon cet
épidémiologiste
il faut limiter le taux de propagation
du virus
la meilleure façon d'y arriver est
d'avoir un vaccin mais à défaut d'en
avoir un les enquêtes et l' isolement
constitue la meilleure stratégie
c'est pour essayer
que ceux qui sont infectieux rentrer en
contact avec ceux qui sont pas encore
infectés pour diminuer cette
transmission là quand on n'a pas
d'autres outils c'est la meilleure
solution à mon avis on peut pas
tellement faire autre chose et bien sûr
il ya un enjeu de capacité
je veux dire on peut pas tester tout le
monde qui a voyagé hors canada s'est pas
faisable donc comme pour n'importe quel
texte on y va par pertinente que ça
avait commencé le 5 qui ont déjà les
gens sont en ce moment plus inquiet mais
réagissent quand même bien en fait ils
sont pas mal au fil ça circule tellement
qu'ils n'ont pas le choix de deux
canettes sont tous beaux mâles assez
compliqué parce que vaincre la coved 19
demandera un effort collectif ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
longueuil